all right we are now live for another
political theory and practice
discussion
uh the topic that i i picked for this
month is a little bit you might say
obscure
in how it's titled but hopefully people
will you know catch on to what i'm
talking about
as we're going through it
and it's the unraveling of political
norms now i'm going to be talking
specifically
about
political norms but we could apply this
to
other areas as well that are you could
say politicized like education
the economy
uh you know daily interactions with with
people so i'll talk about that in a bit
and this is gonna i think seem kind of
far-ranging i'm gonna be bringing in a
number of different thinkers at
different points
not because i have some absolutely well
worked out systematic approach to this
but because i find them
helpful
myself
and i'll try to do as much explaining as
i can do in bringing them up not
assuming that people have all read them
so i'm going to begin
in a a way that might seem a little
simplistic and schematic by bringing up
an essay
by jill duluz
about uh herman melville's bartleby the
scrivener and in significant part about
melville's ideas
in his works
and also what this you know by the end
of the essay uh duluz is talking about
things you know russia america
pragmatism all sorts of other things
as well and we don't need to like focus
on every single aspect or element of the
essay is called barbie or the formula
and the formula that's being referred to
there is the i would prefer not to
and actually you know christie that
might come up later on
as something that is is worth uh talking
about
but what i'm gonna say that i i
particularly like about the loser's
essay and struck me even when i was a
graduate student years and years and
years ago
is that it has to do not specifically
with norms as such but with what deleuze
calls the law which could encompass
norms
ways of articulating how we ought to be
doing things um including sanctions for
for those things as well you know who
should be rewarded who should be
punished why how should we control
people
and deleuze talks about there being
three types of what he calls originals
as opposed to just plain old characters
and
this is in melville but i think we could
apply this to other things as well
so
two are like at antipodes to each other
and you could view them as active and
passive also evil and in a certain
respect good but also kind of a sickly
sort of goodness
the vulnerable so let's start with them
bartleby himself is a messed up
character he clearly cannot function
well
in the law office that he's in and the
the attorney is trying to get to draw
something out of him to get him to be
integrated into the
office billy budd would be another um
good example of this
and um you know billy budd ends up you
know being
it starts out being a damaged character
but also kind of an angelic character
and meets a terrible
end as well
and these are these are people who are
going to be not just vulnerable but also
you could say victimized right
and you could say well why does that
happen and so let's let's swing to the
other end we have um ahab as a
representative of this other demonic
type this megalomaniac as duluz calls
him
clagger the master of arms and billy
budd who has it in for billy budd and
these are the people who are sadistic
they are driven they won't accept
limitations they don't work well with
others and they try to dominate right
and so you could say well the real
problem in society is that you know
these mean people are doing bad stuff to
the vulnerable people and that that
there's something true there right and
so what should restrain them but doesn't
restrain them here's where we get to the
third kind that um deleuze calls
prophets so the captain and billy budd
or the attorney
in um bartleby the scrivener these are
people who
see the problematics of human society
and human interactions and they stand
for
the law with a capital l they are there
to
exercise power
you know in in order to keep order going
and why is order a good thing
order is supposed to be there to
restrain the the a-holes
ahab the a-hole right and to protect the
vulnerable and keep things operating
this is not a unique idea of course
read saint augustine and you will see
all sorts of great discussions about the
the need for order aristotle talks about
this plato talks about this this is a
constant of political theory that we we
cannot do altogether without order you
know there is of course an anarchist
tradition anarchism you know if you
think about it no rule right people
ruling themselves but that's at the
fringes primarily most of the time we
live in societies in which there there
are some
orderings and the orderings can be good
jb bell brings up martin luther king
talking about order versus justice
most of the time order is supposed to be
enshrining justice
so it's not so simple as a dichotomy
between order and justice we see
something similar in john stewart mill
as well you know we've got the forces of
order and conservativism versus the
forces of order and progress
progress is order too it's a it's a
reordering what martin luther king is
talking about order as well but a just
order as opposed to an unjust order so
there's always order there now here's
the problematic that the lose identifies
the jerks the a-holes the the people who
you know are so dynamic and attractive
but are ultimately you know
driven by by
passions that tend to be bad
they don't they not only to respect her
they tear through it like rocks through
spider webs and
the order that's there actually and
follow much more severely onto those who
are more vulnerable to it and should be
protected by it and aren't so we could
think in our own time about the use of
policing you know and we've talked about
this before in political uh theory and
practice discussion several of them
american policing
and it's a mess because there is no
national organized policing thing you do
have something like that go ahead and
look at the british met and you can see
that policing can be increased and
misogynistic and problematic in many
ways but we don't even have that instead
we just have a whole bunch of police
departments and sheriff's departments
and you know state police troopers and
all these sorts of things um kind of at
you know each with their own little
fiefdom and oftentimes victimizing the
very people that they are supposed to
serve and protect sometimes we have
these terrible figures within the police
you know we see these awful revelations
of you know things
the chicago police department is a
particularly egregious example
where they even have like you know
places to take people
so that they don't have to book them and
they can torture them instead of
booking them and stuff like along those
lines but we have that happening here in
milwaukee with uh police who are out of
control we recently had a police officer
fired
after he had killed three people
from the wauwatosa police department and
then immediately hired by the waukesha
sheriff's department so this is a is
serious serious
issue those who are supposed to be doing
the
protecting and guiding
may not be
helping out those who are vulnerable
they may be just serving order itself
and they're like oh it's unfortunate but
i gotta do bad stuff to you
or they may be the the bad actors
themselves and this doesn't this isn't
just a matter of policing this can be a
matter of government this can be a
matter of education this can be a matter
of hospitals
really any place where we have power
relations this is a um this is an issue
um theoretical the sound is a tendency
to be unequal i don't control that
people like to bring that sort of stuff
up youtube automatically controls the
sound don't weigh in about stuff that's
irrelevant to the actual topic all right
so returning and we could say not
everything is the way to lose is
depicting it maybe that's a little bit
too pessimistic right so maybe there is
a social order that exists and it's not
just about protecting order or
protecting the vulnerable or making sure
resources are shared maybe it is about
political contestation maybe it is about
how people
representing different classes different
groups different you know whatever we
have within society can you know make
their claims and articulate what needs
to happen
and jockey with each other
that is politics and we can never fully
get away from politics some great
political theorists have recognized that
ranging from aristotle all the way up to
you know hana rent and jurgen habermas
there will always be competing interests
and there will not only always be
competing interests there will always be
competing conceptions of what the right
thing to do is what the right
arrangement is
and you know we're probably you can get
away from that by by superimposing one
particular point of view but that's
usually going to be unjust and that's
going to victimize an awful lot of
people who are supposed to be if we want
to use the police model protected and
served by the order that is put in place
now
here's where it's all that background
here's where we get to the topic that i
wanted to bring up
here in america you know i'm an american
i've been observing american politics
really since i was uh in in grade school
and we saw the you know reagan versus
carter election my dad was a big fan of
gary hart uh you know we we had civics
classes in school so i've been observing
what's been going on for a long time and
i've participated as a voter and
sometimes as you know an advocate in in
politics um one of the things that i've
observed happening over not just the
last you know presidential uh uh um
reign of trump or anything like that but
over decades
is the gradual
unraveling
of political norms and we we call this
like hyper partisanship right we call
this
factionalization or you know things
along those lines but it really also at
the ground level represent
a
saying i know the norm is this but in
this case i'm going to do this because
that is for the benefit of those i
represent or my party or something like
that that's the right thing to do
and i've seen both parties you know here
in america we have the republicans and
we have the democrats i've seen both
parties doing this in the past like with
how they carry business out in this in
the senate which is a rather cumbersome
institution or the use of executive
decision making to override legislative
decision making on the part of the
presidents and uh all the different
agencies that we have
and you know it's been going on for
quite a while this unraveling this
this abrogating this making exceptions
to what should be
political norms that would would protect
the the process and would keep things
from getting so hyper partisan
i would say that
we've reached a kind of um
tipping point a while back
and at this point in time i would say
that there are some people on the left
and identified with the center-left
democrat party
um maybe not even center left maybe just
center democrat party who you know
certainly have a role in this right if
you're if you're
prioritizing
uh things in such a way that you're
willing to engage in
domestic terrorism
you are clearly or you're calling for
domestic terrorism you are clearly
crossing political lines and going
against any sort of order that would be
not just your order but an order that
would you know sort of govern how things
would work right
and um i would say the republican party
and the conservatives who aren't even
conservative anymore they're
a lot of them are just straight out
fascists or
authoritarians they're not conservative
in the sense of conserving what
conservativism was like 40 years ago
except for the lunatic fringe
they're doing much worse you know when
we see calls to
not just say impeach a legislature or a
executive but to go and kill them
that's that's a a clear line that's been
crossed when we see people within the
political establishment countenancing
this
and advocating this which is you know
quite often the case and those who
resist them within their party being
censured being silenced i mean that's
the real cancel culture there right um
we've got a serious serious problem and
it's a problem that you know
i don't belong to either party right and
i voted for and against both parties
over the course of my time uh oftentimes
voting against the the you know worse
evil against the
lesser evil
those of us who are not affiliated with
the party those who we call independence
were screwed too by this failure for our
government to actually work both at the
federal level and at the state level the
state that i live in here wisconsin is a
great example of that
um and you know it's more of a
thing to blame the republicans for than
the democrats the republicans seem
really cool with trying to have power
for the sake just of power and to rule
as a minority over all the rest of us
the majority um by the way the democrats
were doing crap like that back in the
you know
early 2000s as well and and you know so
it's not as if uh they were the only
people doing that um but this is a very
problematic thing and and
if we get away from just party politics
this gets us to the point where maybe
people are like
none of this [ __ ] works
i'm not gonna worry about either party i
need to protect my interests i need to
protect myself against all these other
people because the political norms are
indeed unraveling and they're not just
unraveling within the political
processes and institutions which have
been corrupt and rotten for a very long
time lobbying you know
these two parties they've they've been
you know totally flush with cash for a
very long time the culture war stuff
that we're engaging in most of the the
the content in the culture war is uh
pretty deleterious to any sort of
functioning society
and you know we could talk about how
this affects education where we've got
you know crazy people coming into school
board meetings and textbooks being now
banned uh if they have you know any
mention of our the history of race in
america
we have a lot of of problematic areas
this factionalization has affected
dating it's affected families it's
affected workplaces
all these sorts of things
if we don't
you know improve this in some way
then
the bad actors
won't you know when they get emboldened
when they see that
there's no sanctions for what they do
when they see that there are laws in
place and they're not applied
when we know that there are for example
regulatory agencies which then are
underfunded so they can't actually go
out and do their work and this is a big
big thing going on in the trump
administration you know think about the
fda the fda turning over for example to
the pork industry its own like you know
uh
checking up on itself terrible idea you
know from for a political community um
it's it's basically letting the bad
actors do whatever they want to do you
know
that demoralizes the hell and angers the
hell out of everybody else who's not
getting
getting to
feed at the trough right and it also
leaves out all those other people to go
back to the duluz thing who are
vulnerable who don't understand how to
make the system work who are at risk of
being
having power what what there is of order
used against them
and we live in a society in which that
is very often the case uh there are a
lot of victimized groups there are a lot
not just for right now but historically
for generations
so
do i have any solution to this i don't
i'm just sort of
you know throwing something out there
that i've been thinking about
and
troubled by and observing i will say
this that
when it comes to this this victimization
you could talk about one one of the
responses that somebody could have is
like it's all nice for you to talk about
order and stuff like that
my group my people have not been
protected by that order for a very long
time and that's right
you know if we think about race for
example alexis de tocqueville back in
the 19th century in the 1840s in his
book democracy in america which is very
bullish about america which says
american democracy and society is
offering us something something new and
robust he's got a chapter where he says
the great sin of america and they're
going to have to figure this out is what
they've done to the black and the red
race meaning uh africans and uh native
americans
that was back in the 1800s you know
people were seeing this
it's not something radically new uh it
is an integral part of our history i
would suggest that you know anybody who
thinks that there's like a social
contract that covers everybody should
probably read you know charles mills the
racial contract that's that's a good
work to think about we could think about
gender and we could think about
sexuality and we could think about
poverty and all these things
intersecting with each other
we could think about all the other ways
in which power winds up being used on
people and maybe somebody like foucault
could be very helpful in helping us see
that and maybe people like if we want to
reconstruct something decent maybe we
would bring in theorists like
habermas or arendt or you know whoever
else we can we can bring to the table
but again i don't have a solution to
this i just see a big looming problem
and um i i'll finish by bringing in hubs
i've got my anti-leviathan
shirt here
thomas hobbs is often misunderstood
with his whole state of nature and then
the sovereign thing he does bring that
up that's a rhetorical construct
hobbes was worried about something
happening again in england like the
english civil war that he lived through
where people were contesting not just
who was going to have power
but what made power legitimate what made
things okay or not okay and when you've
got people who can't agree on the
fundamentals of what would be just or
unjust let alone facts about things like
you know is wearing masks a good
idea for preventing covet right
or do vaccines contain microchips that
allow bill gates to control my mind
we're in we're in bad uh territory right
there's a tendency to like devolve into
a hobbesian
dynamic which is never a pure state of
nature it's rather factionalized society
in which war gets carried on within that
society and when we have people
calling for a new american civil war
we're clear we're clearly close to the
hobbsian uh point of view aren't we so
that's enough uh uh that we'll see how
many relevant things we have
uh here williams and any thoughts on how
uh you manage singapore do you think a
virtue ethicist could have supported him
i don't know enough about singapore to
weigh in on that um and i don't know
maybe a virtue ethicist could maybe a
virtue ethicist couldn't but i don't
know how that's particularly relevant to
this one
um
jb our uh rcmp
uh royal canadian mounted police in
canada has a very bad problem with
sexism and other bigotries here it's
more of the native people who get
horribly maltreated yeah canada has an
uh at this point in time an equally
terrible
record i mean i'm actually ashamed to
say as somebody who's a family is
french-canadian and knowing you know the
different paradigm that the french had
for a very long time in relations with
native americans or first peoples that
the quebecois have treated the people
that you know they deal with like the
mohawk like like crap as well right so
this is this is a significant problem
and you know one of the great examples
of what's going on so that this trucker
uh uh whatever you want to call it right
i would call it trucker riots i i
wouldn't call them uh strikers i would
call it you know outside agents for the
most part and people who are uh rich
enough to be able to take two weeks off
of work and um you know park their
trucks somewhere and you know wave their
flags and all that sort of stuff
whatever we want to call it
people are noticing that when it came to
like blocking pipelines
you know the police were there on the
spot ready to crack heads
and they're not there
for these people who are
really you know placing uh
cities in a state of siege and screwing
up the economy there's a there's a
disjunction there right when you look at
that you're like
the political order is really helping
out some people and these are clearly
bad actors you know i mean you start
looking into it the the paypal is used
for money laundering you know i mean we
could go on and on and on and people who
are like trying to protect the
environment and say hey don't don't put
a pipeline on our land they get the
stick they get the water cannon
there's something
really off about that right
um
francis what do you think of the
abolition of work i don't think that's
going to happen
that's a non-starter right um
where where do you see that as something
that's likely to
occur in the
situations that we live in in our
lifetime i mean we could say there might
be an abolition of work in the sense
that work gets taken away from everybody
because of ai
and uh you know our incredibly complex
logistics system and robotics and stuff
like that which then just enriches the
people who own all that that sort of
stuff and we wound up you know we could
think about marx right
and you know marx is actually right on a
lot of things certain types of
industrial processes combined with with
capitalist processes sometimes produce
the state where the worker doesn't have
any work right that's very different
than being in like a post-scarcity
future which i don't see happening in
america any time
uh chesty alicat thanks for speaking up
i'm a socialist in general yeah i mean
socialists here in the united states um
there's not a hell of a lot of them to
begin with but you know they they get
this socialist slur against them uh
because you know conservatives for i
don't know how how far do we go back
really the whole 20th century and the
the uh
our century have been like using it as a
slur term so very few people who
actually are against socialism know what
the health socialism even means
um but you know we could talk about
third party positions or third party
perspectives they're like totally shut
out of our
[Music]
our uh political processes i mean you
can say the libertarians have a little
bit of edge with the republicans but not
much you know
so all right max wouldn't you feel that
a city like chicago's police department
wouldn't be given any credence at home
north washington to reduce strict
behavior aggressive to any or all
criminals i don't know what that means
i'm not sure
what you're asking there
given credence
to reduce strict behavior aggressive to
any i mean here's the point
chicago pd is pretty pretty corrupt
right it's been corrupt for a long time
it's it's uh
there's a lot of people who are i would
say objectively evil individuals
existing within its ranks and there is
no accountability i mean and the mayor
uh who should be doing something about
it she backs them up most of the time
right
um
so chicago is in a bad way you know it's
kind of funny because you get you get
these like outsiders who are like oh
look at chicago guns everywhere people
are shooting each other it's so bad you
know why it's bad it's bad because
criminals aren't being dealt with and
the cops are are so you know so much you
know basically knee-jerk right-wing
conservative uh kill-happy people
that uh
they're not gonna do anything about it
really they love the the status quo you
know um you you know whenever you see
people from the outside of a city
criticizing that city and they don't
know much about it just take it for
granted that there's there's they're
getting fed something
by
media and politicians that identify with
their side and they don't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about you know um
you want to know what's going on in
chicago you got to follow chicago news
you got to know some people
that are actually on the ground same
thing with milwaukee right chicago and
milwaukee not the same thing you know so
i mean i wouldn't like say a lot about
baltimore police because i don't know
so
all right um
chest the alley cat i think rawls is
more important than ever right now
yeah i
mean a lot of rawls stuff is kind of
non-starters though
it's interesting if you think about the
veil of ignorance experiment when we
actually do this in classes
i found it never pans out the way that
rawls says it's going to maybe that
works for like students at harvard back
in the 1960s and 70s and 80s it sure as
hell didn't work for
students in southern illinois in the
late 90s or
my prison students in indiana state
prison in the early 2000s or my other
students in you know new york and here
in milwaukee when i've proposed it in
the late 2000s and
you know the 2010s
um so i i you know
and you're in rolls is is quite complex
to read it's not like you can take his
thoughts and easily
present and condense them um
so i i don't know i i don't see rawls is
really all that that helpful um
but you know if we could if things were
better maybe he would be right
uh that might actually be a sign of like
the disconnect between
academically informed political theory
and what's actually happening within our
society you know
mark says i was having an interesting
discussion with a student earlier about
the difference between the failure of
the state versus that of the government
how to discriminate between them this is
a really great question
and i think we could actually say not
just the failure of
this is kind of aristotelian the the
state and the government you know or
actually aristotle would say the pulitea
right the the constitution
and then the regime the people who are
actually in charge
we can make distinctions between them
right we make distinctions every
election when we vote the current set of
bozos out and we bring a new set of
hopefully not bozos in
uh bozo by the way was bozo the clown
you know so that's that's kind of an
american slaying thing uh of a certain
generation um buzz of the clown by the
way is from chicago
uh i used to get to watch that when i
was a kid if the the weather was just
right so the antenna could actually pick
it up
so you know in a way in functioning
democracies we already do make a
distinction between the the state or the
mode of governance right and the people
doing it
what we're seeing
is that the the middle part the
institutions that
you know get things done that get
politics working that allocate funds
those are starting to be torn apart and
be you know usurped in for purely
partisan
ways right
um and that's that's really problematic
now you know it's unfortunate that that
we have to wait until like when it comes
to presidents we don't have like a vote
of no confidence where we can say get
this this a-hole out of here they're not
doing a good job i mean even if we did
of course then we'd have constant
lobbying by whoever's in the opposition
to do that i mean that's that's
basically what the republicans tried to
do to obama isn't it uh you know as soon
as he came in a lot of this was driven
you know clearly just by racism
um they're like this guy is not going to
be able to do anything
you know we're not going to work with
him on anything he's a socialist he's a
barack hussein obama he's he's a you
know islamic catalyst he's he's uh for
black liberation theology didn't make
all sorts of [ __ ] up right but they
didn't want to work with him on anything
and you know the the the democrats had
enough power at that time to push things
through but they you know they managed
to lose control over a lot of the states
at the same time
so you know there's a good example of
uh you know the opposition was totally
against that regime
and they wanted to as soon as they got
in power they wanted to use that
politea they wanted to use the apparatus
of power for whatever they wanted to do
and you know you noticed too with the
biden
regime it's a big disappointment to a
lot of people who wanted trump out
because
biden is doing a lot of the same stuff
and there's the same thing with obama
right when it comes to like um
i mean not foreign policy in some
respects i mean trump was like there's
not a dictator that trump wouldn't kiss
the ass of right um
and and so that's a little bit different
but when it comes to like
continuing the war on terror and
military budgets and all this sort of
stuff
the the biden regime is
not that different than the trump regime
except in you know the cruelty being
done in different ways we could say the
same thing about the bush regime to the
obama regime you know
drone strikes for example right so
sometimes there's there's an important
uh
it seems like there's a difference but
but there's a real continuity there
between regimes because the politea
requires that we could think about
america
as a weird unique dangerous case you
know the hyper power as we were called
in the 90s and early 2000s where we have
this massive
military force that we can project
and um you know we still have a lot of
economic force as well um and so we're
in we're in kind of an unusual
case um
and you know maybe to the detriment of
i won't say the rest of the world
because i mean do you really want like
you know the chinese in charge of the
russians in charge maybe not right
um
lc regulatory agencies are captured yeah
that often happens i mean
here in america unfortunately another
issue that we have is regulatory
agencies the ones that are doing a lot
of the heavy lifting you could say right
you get you get a bad person in there as
a political appointee and then it's
tough to get them out especially now
when our political decision making about
who to appoint to positions is extremely
partisan you know um you know we got
that that that
prime example that terrible post
postmaster general joy you know
why couldn't they just kick him out well
it takes takes a lot to do you know
um
let's see jb bell says not so much cuis
custode custodes who's you know guarding
the guardians right as ubi custodes
where where are the guardians
i mean in some respect we got too many
guardians right we got too many people
jocking for i want to be the guardian
and most of them are shitty guardians
they're they're in it for themselves
they're in it for their party they're
not really you know here's where again
we could bring in a great aristotelian
distinction
what differentiates a monarchy from a
tyranny
it doesn't differentiate it on the basis
of one person rule or an aristocracy an
oligarchy it's not just that it's the
rich versus the good it's the
who is being looked out for if you are a
monarch in a real sense a basilise right
then you look out for the entirety of
the society
including even perhaps criminals you
know you don't just say well they're the
enemies so let's kill them all
you say how can we
work things out together so that the
common good which has got to be not just
a common good of like the nation as a
whole or the state as a whole
but good of of the people involved in it
how do we make that happen whereas the
tyrant is like me me me me me me and
those who you know kiss my butt uh
everybody else screw them and
aristotle talks about the difference
between two types of what we would call
democracy right where the many rule
in some cases it's the many ruling
and they're actually looking out for the
rest of society
not just their own interests not just
their own party
not just their own race their own class
whatever we want to pick and then
there's the greedy i only care about
myself you know prime example of this
are all the people who you know changed
their position on kovid because somebody
close to them died right they're like
until then they're like it's all a hoax
screw all the immune compromised people
we don't want this that is going against
freedom and then suddenly somebody close
to them dies and like now i get it well
no you didn't get it you didn't work for
the common good you only care about
yourself and your little class or your
little group
that's what aristotle thinks democracy
often devolves into and
if democracy is going to actually work
it can't look like that it's got to be
this other kind over here
where
there can be some self-interest there
can be some partisanship but it better
not that better not be running the show
you know parties better be able to work
together and
that's not the case here hasn't been the
case um for a long time
just the alley cat you get tangled up in
a group's rhetoric and it inhibits you
from seeing things clearly very emotive
yeah that that i mean i would say
a lot of the people
who are
tied in and very passionate about party
politics right now
have been suckered there i mean there's
some great articles out there
about how trump essentially and the
trump regime essentially were a bunch of
um scammers
you know con men and the one thing that
a person has been conned will not do in
most cases is recognize that they've
been conned and it's a really sad part
of that uh in this case unfortunately we
had to you know have uh
thousands of people well million you
know at this point worldwide millions of
people hundreds of thousands of
americans die due to something that
could have been taken care of you know
our coveted response
almost counterproductive from the
federal level during the trump regime
and it enabled people at the state level
to do all sorts of crazy crap as well if
this had been happening during reagan's
administration you can bet
that there would have been mask mandates
across the board we would have been
working for universal inoculation none
of this crazy [ __ ] would have been
tolerated you know but that you know
we're in a different place now
so
uh kirkland day what do you think about
the conflict of the west versus russia
and china i mean i think it's been going
on for a while
what's new to report
right uh
we've got some jockeying uh we've got
some some uh
turning you know countries into proxies
and stuff like that going on um we have
different ways of looking at things i
mean it's very clear that as opposed to
like if this had been happening in the
the 60s or 70s
um china is is driving the car russia is
just for like a long for the ride russia
is um
you know
russia is not going to do well going
forward i mean you look at the society
you know um
negative growth rates right
an economy that's just a hot mess the
need to engage in jingoism clearly
non-free press
china is on the rise i mean there's a
lot of problems in china including you
know some that that aren't all that well
known but
china is going to be a major player in
this this century so
uh mock says uh tocqueville definitely
ahead of his time probably centuries
into the future definitely beyond
today's current age
yeah i guess so i mean
he's uh he i think the tocqueville is
kind of
un undeservedly neglected
and he's been kind of seeded over to
middle road conservatives who want to
talk about american exceptionalism
and i think one of the things that they
forget is that de tocqueville is
identifying this as in the america of
the 1840s there's no guarantee that the
dynamics that he saw
last right maybe maybe america is
quite different than what de tocqueville
was identifying as opposed to european
democracies and maybe some other places
are more to talk villain in that respect
than current america is right so
all right um
[Music]
jb appropriate to invoke the english
civil war
because people in the usa talking about
civil war don't appreciate it would be
more like that one oh yeah this is a
very interesting point it would be more
like the english civil war and not like
the american civil war from history
yeah i mean the american civil war
itself was very complicated you know
there's a lot of people who are like
well you have the north and the south
and it wasn't about slavery it was about
states rights you know and you know when
i was in high school one of the standard
essays that we had was identify the 11
causes of the american civil war and
number one was slavery right but there
were all sorts of other things going on
as well
and the southerners not only enslaved
blacks they also indentured a lot of
whites as well usually poor whites made
them work basically as slaves um there
were rebellions against the the south in
the south in a lot of different places
they had to be crushed by southern
troops um there there were you know
states that were
considered not in rebellion even though
they weren't really supporting the union
like missouri
and kentucky right um there are other
states like wisconsin one of the things
that i'm very proud of here in our
heritage is the which we've kind of lost
sight of unfortunately especially if you
go out into the countryside is
anti-racism and abolitionism this was
one of the most uh you know committed
states to those causes and and we
contributed more than our fair share of
soldiers to the american civil war as a
result you know so that you've already
got a complicated american civil war the
english civil war
was similarly driven
by
ideological perspectives and the
breakdown of that society the breakdown
of
the political community you could say
that's why hobbs writes leviathan he
sees this and i don't want to say his
solution is the right one but you know
um
it's uh
you know it's we should take a look at
it and we should think about others we
could we could also look at other
societies that are closer in time where
social breakdown occurs and they ask why
is that the case
you know um
i think anybody who talks about a
national divorce or a civil war in
positive terms um if if our society was
functioning well we would censure them
we would say
get the hell out of here because you
don't belong at the table if you're
going to be playing around with this
sort of stuff you don't get to talk like
the adults you know
um
so
all right uh
lc do you see an air of multipolarity
emerging at the geopolitical level maybe
we're seeing the start of a similar
dispersion at home less dem and
republican more diverse coalitions so
two different questions there i i would
say were
it would be wonderful if we had more
diverse coalitions
unfortunately the republican and the
democratic parties have a complete lock
on american politics all the way down to
the local level there are a few
exceptions like there's some
libertarians in texas and and indiana
but the libertarians tend to caucus with
the um
with the republicans anyway so who cares
right you're just a republican by a
different name
um
it's interesting to see how you know the
libertarians who are all about freedom
are super cool with fascism uh so long
as it's directed not at them but again
say black people
[Music]
the other parties the green party
there's really uh not much of it going
on
i i don't see it as a viable party or
the constitution party or any of the
other parties that are that are around
as well so i don't i don't see a lot of
coalition politics going on
unfortunately unless your coalition
happens to have money right because
that's really what drives this the most
and it's it's you know the donations are
being made by big think tanks big
philanthropists and by
uh corporations you know for every soros
there's a [ __ ] right
and then you've got
all these corporations that are spending
oftentimes on both sets of candidates
i don't see that changing i wish it
could change but i don't see that
changing now at the geopolitical level
very different right we we clearly have
a waning of u.s influence in part
because we piss away so much of our
budget on a military trying to stay
strong
not realizing that
this position is not going to last
forever and we're impoverishing
ourselves at home you know i mean
the other powers are in effect doing to
us what we did to the to the soviet
union the soviet union collapsed in part
because it couldn't deliver on economic
promises and
promises about culture to its people and
it couldn't do that because they were
spending so much of their money on the
military preparing for world war iii um
we we instead of preparing for world war
iii prepare for all this asymmetric
warfare and bombing the [ __ ] out of
people with carrier groups and that's
extraordinarily expensive you know and
continual drone warfare and things like
that right and
that's unsustainable
so we will eventually shift to a
multi-polar
sort of thing in international relations
the question is who are the polls going
to be clearly china right
probably russia i mean although russia
is sort of like russia is sort of like
what turkey was like uh the the sick man
of europe in uh leading up to world war
one right
clearly of the united states and clearly
the eu whether britain will play a major
role
remains to be seen
india is also a significant player
brazil has the the opportunity if they
ever get their their collective crap
together which may not happen because of
all the political infighting and the
incredible poverty
uh they could become a major power they
have the potential to do so um
iran perhaps you know iran is a regional
superpower saudi arabia is a regional
superpower as well but will they be so
when the oil runs out
maybe not you know
so there's a lot of uh there's a lot of
possibility for
for a multi-polar and we're talking
about like probably when i'm an old man
and dying and some of you are that as
well and some of you are young people in
your middle age it's not going to happen
like tomorrow but there's there's a good
chance for it
giovanni soda not a real question just
wanted to say i'm preparing my
dissertation on human to lose and your
video on them are great help both glad
that you you find them helpful you know
um i always like to see
um
uh
you know
attention to the text and i'm sure that
you're reading the text so that's great
here we have somebody who wants to
contest things trucker riots watch some
of the live streams it's one of the
nicest protests i've ever seen yeah it's
real nice to like have stuff shut down
and see nazi flags and and you know uh
the bastardization of the american flag
that is the blue lives matter flag
that's really nice yeah i love that sort
of [ __ ] you know
and they're real nice to people who are
their kind um so yeah i'm sure i'm sure
you love them um and that's probably all
i need to say right mark i've been
thinking lately about what mcintyre says
about the requisite virtues courage
justice truthfulness for our practice
and how many institutions are failing at
preserving these shows yeah and actually
so what mark is talking about there is
deep in the heart of after virtue which
is a really great work everybody should
read it you know
going back to the roles you know
everybody should probably read uh rawls
justice you know
theory of justice i almost said justice
is fairness that's just the sort of
nutshell idea but a theory of justice
but everybody should instead if you
don't read the walls read mcintyre read
after virtue and
mcintyre makes the case that
institutions are not enough we need to
cultivate communities communities of
inquiry communities of you know
developing virtue and this has to happen
every single generation
right
and communities can sicken and go the
wrong direction you know there's no
guarantee to any of these things and he
identifies three virtues as particularly
needed truthfulness or honesty you know
um something
missing if you're a partisan right
because then you have to lie to yourself
and others about you know what you're
actually doing you can't take an
objective view you know
justice
justice not for you but also for other
people within the society and courage
the courage to stand up against your own
groups to police to your own
if you can't do that if your courage is
only directed against the enemy
you're not courageous you're actually
gutless that's a that's a big problem in
our our political uh uh parties and
communities
um
massac when canadian hogs wave the
confederate flags we've done messed up
as a country yeah and again i'll say as
a wisconsinite
i think and i'm making i'm gonna write
this up eventually
our tradition our historical tradition
is killing rebels killing confederates
right that's if you go down wisconsin
avenue we have a civil war statue and it
shows three union soldiers trampling a
confederate rebel soldier into the dust
who's been killed that's our tradition i
think that anybody who has a confederate
flag on their car on their shirt they
ought to be whipped
they ought to be beaten
they ought to have corporal punishment
used against them
that flag ought to be burned maybe
covered with [ __ ] because that's what it
deserves it's a sign
just of devotion to racism and white
power
and to see that
in wisconsin to see that in canada which
is where the underground railroad was
going shows that the level of corruption
of the people
who are racists
in that country
it shouldn't be tolerated it should be
like
nazi uh memorabilia in germany if you if
you use it you get you get dinged you
know i think that's we should we should
uphold our traditions of anti-racism and
abolitionism
and you know being for the union
those are equally valid traditions for
all those gross disgusting you know
mahistory people who want to wave
confederate flags
they shouldn't be we shouldn't give them
the opportunity to claim history we
should have history coming down on them
like a like a boot you know
you can tell i'm pretty passionate about
that but i've been thinking about that
for years you know
kirkland interesting your point about
work abolition in china they they
believe they should build up the
productive forces while safeguarding the
socialist movement roughly
yeah maybe they do maybe they don't i
remember how shocked i was at one of the
recent party congresses and this is back
in the early 2000s when the communist
party said we're not really so much
about protecting the workers anymore and
i was like holy [ __ ]
that's big
they just said that they're
you know they're in charge they're
basically like going back to mandarin
china you know where the elites rule and
they'll they'll look out for the poor
and the workers if they want to but if
not too bad it's not going to be the
main focus so i i don't know i wouldn't
i wouldn't trust uh that that sort of uh
uh buying into things
um
all right uh
let's see who else we've got here paul
lit here i'm vaccinated but strongly
opposed to mandates mandates are too
politically volatile it will further
increase partisanship how can we balance
public health and individual freedom of
choice well guess what you can't you
can't balance what what the people who
are crazy call individual freedom of
choice you don't coddle them you don't
say oh they're gonna get upset if we
have a mandate
no that's ridiculous that's playing into
their hands
we've tolerated enough stupid nonsense
[ __ ] from all these anti-vaxxers
you know we should actually have
mandates we should enforce mandates and
and if they don't like it
screw them
the only reason we can't is because we
can't trust the damn cops to actually
enforce the law because so many of them
are nut job right-winger anti-vaxxers
right
if we actually had a functioning society
and decent people in police offices we
would have no problem enforcing mandates
but we don't
so there's no reason why we should be
like namby pamby about this and be oh
you don't want to make them upset
they're already upset they're not jobs
you can't actually reason with them
so that's a non-starter as far as i'm
concerned you know
uh jb bell rawls is relative irrelevance
in the current very hot context are
there any other philosophers you think
are helpful for these times i like the
stoics of course but maybe more
contemporary i mean i think the stoics
are actually quite useful in when
they're understood all the stoics were
committed to their societies that is a
central part of it they fought in civil
wars they were willing to be exiled they
actually did a plot against uh the
emperor nero to get rid of them you know
this is the part of stoicism that
doesn't get brought out enough it's all
this this stupid like you know uh scammy
broissism i'm gonna be a tough guy at
the gym and take cold showers [ __ ]
you know and they don't actually read
the real stoics and see what they they
did i think there's a lot of potential
there i think you know any sort of
neo-aristotelianism and there's plenty
of them out there like mcintyre um you
know we could use that um i think that
that people who are
influenced uh by them could be quite
helpful as well so you know and when we
do have to address you know i think we
need to look at radical philosophy uh
we do have to address misogyny we do
have to address uh you know
long-standing exist long-standing
patterns of racism that isn't just
individual racism in a conscious way but
there is structural racism we do need to
address that sort of stuff instead of
trying to hide it or you know demonize
it as crt you know they'll move on from
that because last year it was post
modernism and next year it'll be
something different right all the the
the people who are motivated solely by
their own
little fears right
um there's a lot that we could be using
all right um
christopher any thoughts on the supreme
court taking up affirmative action at
universities uh you know the last time
we took it up was uh sandra day o'connor
i think wrote the
um
the majority view and she said in about
20 years
uh we're gonna have to revisit this so
it's probably a good time to to revisit
it right
um
oh here's an interesting point kirkland
day democrats stop progress and
republicans reverse it and that's
actually a pretty good way to talk about
it republicans at this point in time
you know i i've voted republican in the
past i've actually you know supported
republican candidates at the local level
it is disgusting
what republicans have allowed themselves
to turn into
the the incredible corruption
and you know all the sort of like worst
parts of of human nature and our
political history coming to the fore and
becoming central
you know um and the democrats pretty
ineffective you know they're they're
always getting like rope-a-doped by the
the republicans you're like what is
wrong with you people you know and and
you get the idea that that quite a few
of them don't actually believe in
and any of the progressive things that
they they you know make claims about and
part of this is part of the problem is
we do have a political elite you know
uh there's so much money to be made in
being in charge i mean look at look at
the obamas and the clintons how rich
they are you know were they that rich
before
office no
um
you know we could plenty of plenty of
other examples so
uh boy uh king galores really wants to
be the contrarian here trump wasn't
nearly as bad as the media made him he
was actually worse than the media you
made him you just got to pay close
attention i'm not quite sure why
you want to try to like uh
say things that are
again it's almost like playing
rope-a-dope you know
um
all right uh
just skipped a little bit let's see who
else we've got here
um
[Music]
theory dekul can we have a segment on
ignorance soon as in people not knowing
what they're talking about i mean why
would we need a segment on that that's
that's perennial right
uh kirkland if you look at the meeting
between trump and kim jong-un the media
and established figures were heavily
critical that was the most diplomacy
scene from the u.s to the president than
ever before
we're not even going to bother to try to
address that the most diplomacy ever
before yeah sure nixon and china try
that on
uh wada we need the philosopher king and
queen now
wouldn't that be nice but i don't think
that complex societies really admit of
that and when have we seen that um in in
history really working you know we could
say oh marcus aurelius you know um
frederick the great had ambitions to be
the philosopher king um
it doesn't well actually queen christina
of sweden uh probably you know that's
why she wanted some tutorials from
descartes who she brought up and then he
got sick and died
um i don't see that as
you know it's sort of like
when we
we've got this kind of simplistic
thinking if we only change the top
leadership everything would be better no
because there's all sorts of other
problems
down below and that's what brings people
up into the top leadership you know
so
all right uh kenneth chin thoughts on
joe rogan backlash i think joe rog i can
i can never take joe rogan seriously
he's just the guy who made people eat
bugs on fear factor and somehow he
captured a zeitgeist among people who
you know thought it was cool to like
talk about alternative views
um he's i i don't take him seriously at
all as a human being or a public
intellectual
and um you know i'd rather see him
he's not actually being canceled if you
can whine about cancer culture on other
platforms you're not cancelled
i'd love to see him go away you know i
think he's actually a deleterious
influence on american culture
um
kirkland day another silly thing the
ukraine crisis seems manufactured by
america u.s says war is coming in a week
yes ukraine says u.s is overstepping and
creating unnecessary tension
yeah i mean
manufactured
anytime you've got like some big picture
easy
this is this is exactly what's happening
thing you're probably buying somebody
else's misinformation so you probably
want to look at your sources where
you're getting that stuff from
chris if anything rawls is less relevant
today compared to say raymond goyce who
makes questions such as who whom that is
in any actual society who has power what
do they use it for who suffers as a
result yeah i mean that's that's
probably
true i mentioned habermas i've brought
up foucault here there's plenty of
people who are probably more relevant
than rawls
it's amazing how rawls captured the
political imagination for so long in in
american political theory
um
all right uh kirkland day obvious
comparisons between roman washington
people love to do oh what about ancient
rome that's silly too we're much more
like i've said this many many times you
want to read a book that will actually
give you an idea
about where we are willem shires uh the
the fall of the french third republic
he's he's much more famous for the rise
and fall of the third reich
uh the
conditions that we're seeing in in
america the political gridlock the
overspending on a military that we use
in in wrong ways all those sorts of
things
quite similar to what is going on in
france leading up to their fall to the
nazis in the 1940s so
the um it's sort of an old you know um
chestnut you know we're like ancient
rome um no we're not like ancient rome
that's that's really not what's going on
um
all right
do anti-gay doesn't libertarianism
basically just end up in a monarchy
anyway if you take it all the way it
shouldn't
i mean
libertarianism if it really stays true
to itself and i think a lot of
libertarians are not true to their own
libertarianism because they they really
are in it for some other reason
um it there should be like a continual
like bargaining going on between people
about how power is going to be used and
the government should be relatively
small so
all right um
bien
bien
i feel politics is but a masquerade
today because that most citizens are
super uneducated about the world so they
cannot express a thoughtful opinion a
functioning collaborative system we need
this is a big problem here in america um
and you know though
anybody who's trying to like restrain
education so it can't talk about certain
topics um is probably contributing to
that you know we have incredible
innumeracy and
functional illiteracy
people aren't media literate they buy
into things all too easily
and um
yeah we we need better citizens in order
to have
in general
in order to have a functioning
society but i am not super optimistic
about that
um
tom i'm a canadian who has numerous
friends in ottawa trust me this has been
far from a nice protest local residents
have been unrelentingly harassed yeah i
mean that's that's evidence of those of
us paying attention outside of canada
you know um
all right uh
let's see who else we have um
uh
jonathan says how are you analyzing the
ukraine crisis currently i'm not
analyzing i'm just watching it i'm
watching to see how it plays out seems
like russia wants to use it to you know
whip up uh nationalist fervor and
distract its its citizens as it's been
doing for a long time from how um
how many problems there are in in russia
so
yeah um
let's see here
[Music]
i'm gonna have to get going pretty soon
we'll see if there's anything
good here
and in the the things uh northern
bohemian realist i grew up in chippewa
falls now live in deforest you're
correct about the progressive history of
our state yeah i mean i wouldn't say it
if i didn't know that that was the case
you know i've actually done some some
research on our
uh sixth governor alexander randall
who's the guy who actually wanted to
have wisconsin secede from the union if
lincoln wasn't elected right it wasn't
secession and states rights wasn't just
a thing for the southerners right
i'm gonna have to get going pretty soon
because my daughter and i are gonna be
spending some time together my oldest
daughter up here at uwm
um
osh how do you feel about the
normalization of racism in parts of the
world outside of the neoliberal paradigm
like in turkey much of south america
russia japan i'm against racism i think
racism is uh inherently
uh
evil and people who want to justify it
and are invested in that really need to
look at their own character and their
own justifications why they would
deliberately
prioritize something like that that's
usually because of their own damage and
trauma sometimes it's because they're
bad people and you know are they as bad
as other people who are also doing other
bad things maybe not uh depends on the
case right
there's all sorts of gradations but
racism in general is is bad and you know
when we eventually get past it as we do
uh either either we get past it or we
don't um you know uh but the the grand
historical arc has been getting past
silly stupid [ __ ] that people wanted
to buy into
i know there's a lot of regression going
on right now but you know
we can look forward to a time when maybe
that's not going to be how people divide
up the world you know and damage
themselves
um
antigua you shouldn't be allowed to keep
your kid from getting the vaccine that's
where it irritates me yeah you can't
keep your kids from getting the vaccines
for other stuff although there are you
know all the stupid anti i don't want to
get my kid inoculated for measles
there's actually people nowadays the
anti-vaxx thing has gone so far people
get injured and they won't take a
tetanus shot that's how stupid or crazy
some of this anti-vac stuff has gotten
you know
yeah you if you're not going to get get
your kids vaccinated um
maybe you don't get to participate in
society i'm i'm perfectly fine with that
sort of thing that seems reasonable to
me
thomas gerard abraham lincoln
philosopher statesman yeah somebody who
who i think is is quite good
uh bead as an ottoman with no real dog
in the fight of the protest it's
immensely frustrating to see the
co-opting of american revolutionary
symbols most notably the gads and flags
1776 never happened here that's right
the people who are flying that sort of
stuff don't even know their own history
and they're trying to import something
it would be as if we were gonna i mean
the republicans basically should just
import russian flags because a lot of
them are in the pocket of the russians
including our senator ron johnson here
in wisconsin who i hope to god gets
voted out right um
it's it's it's very transgressive it's
not something you know
good to be bringing these these sorts of
things in
um
all right uh
rt whitby joe rogan isn't a public
intellectual never claim to be you don't
have to claim to be to be one
i mean he's he's the sort of bottom of
the barrel is what we've got
you know
um
let's see who else we can we can take
too um
so there's some questions here from wada
about the electoral college it
streamlines the voting process it
protects the country from herd mentality
but it seems every election it's in the
news for being archaic an artifact of an
old system yeah the electoral college is
just crap i mean it's outlived its
purpose we can't really fix it
unfortunately because of our political
gridlock but
we need something better you know
and i mean
right now
it really benefits a minority to try to
try to rule so
um
and and how would you replace it
probably with something more like a
parliamentary system where there's
there's closer direct representation you
know
um
oh here's a good question from osh i
wouldn't consider myself politically
literate as such i don't try to have
opinions on politics people say i'm
morally wrong for my willful quietness i
i don't think you're morally wrong
i mean it is important as a citizen to
to develop some degree of political
literacy but i don't i actually think if
you don't know much about something
you're probably better off not just like
picking an idea out of the air and
saying i'm going to run with this right
we've already got enough people like
that so
all right uh
chris says it looks like the right is in
a cul-de-sac with that with wanting
lesser public spending such as education
how can a democracy sustain itself from
corruption if the people have been
corrupted as well
those two different issues right the the
right is not actually for less
government or less less spending they
just want to control it
i mean that that's pretty clear because
as soon as they get the chance to rule
they don't actually uh i mean they they
are for privatization and that usually
means privatizing to their cronies their
buddies the people that they went to
school with and stuff like that but
that's still keeping it within the
political system right it's still money
going to somebody to do something so i i
don't think that that i think that the
right in the past and the republican
party in the past was for small
government they haven't been for small
government
since um
the bush era we saw a massive expansion
of government in part because of the war
on terror
even reagan wasn't consistent on that he
was for like deregulation when he wanted
to but not for other things
you know he played off of that
anti-government rhetoric but he didn't
really live up to it all that much
all right pumbaa this whole thing the
whole thing hits home for me the
terrifying notion of confirmation bias
or maybe group identification
i mean
so here's the good news and this is what
i'll end on because i'm a little bit
over time
what we're going through is not
radically new
people act like a holes all the time
throughout all history all you got to do
is you know spend some time you know
looking at other eras other places and
you see that there's you know people
exploiting the political process there's
corruption going on there's groups that
come up with crazy ideas and then push
it on to their
their membership and and you know all
sorts of factions and stuff like that
you know i mentioned hobbs
seeing an evil
english civil war play out and writing
books about it by the way he has a book
about the english civil war called
behemoth that's the companion piece to
the leviathan
um
so it you know things are not great
things are actually in many respects and
and for many people particularly those
who are easy to victimize those who lack
power who lack prestige who lack money
who have been historically uh
marginalized or discriminated against
things are hard for them very hard for
them and unfairly hard right
but this is not unprecedented
you know we figured out as human beings
how to get through this before
now of course we have some other
significant challenges you know the
climate change issue which is very easy
to see just look outside here in
wisconsin and uh you can tell that
climate change has taken place and we're
not able to really do much about that um
we have some other looming problems on
the horizon but it's it's not the end of
the world right
um people have been screw-ups for a long
time
politics when it's working well is
trying to figure out how to make this
work
how to
you know
not arrive at ideal perfect solutions
but workable solutions that can make
people's lives better that can restore
some justice to uh where it's lacking so
that's what i'll end on um thanks for
everybody for your questions and
comments and
we'll do this again next month i'll
figure out a good topic for next month
and
got some other online events happening
i'll see you later on